Clinton or Trump it's time for America
to decide we've gotten to a place very
far from our founding fathers and it's a
little bit scary what is it there's
motivating them to gopher for Trump
rather than Clinton well part of the
explanation comes in this income level
you'd be watching the results and coming
in as they've been captured over the
young master so first Clinton goes ahead
then Trump in weaklings could
potentially win it just without Florida
that famous red cap that Donald Trump
has been wearing for the whole of his
campaign they were throwing them out
like sweets and a crowd here we're going
up salutely mad the ones that voted for
a large degree of them voted against
Trump not for Hillary Clinton New
Hampshire sky saying too close to school
so it's another one the number one thing
is we do not want Hillary Clinton in the
White House the Trump's watching there
with the vice presidential running mate
Donald Trump again a nose in front
forty-nine point four against Hillary
Clinton forty eight there with and
Virginia still too close to call
electoral votes is how you become
president of the United States of
America or just give them a bit of a
wiper they're onto the martinis now here
this does feel a lot like the fall in
the pound that we saw on the 23rd of
June a very big fall indeed on the for
the from the Mexican peso in for the New
York Times is running a live results
forecast and it's got now an 80%
probability that Donald Trump will win
the presidency
[Music]
ohayo looks pretty certainly to go for
Donald Trump and what does this mean or
the United States on the world stage
genuinely don't know we'll accept it
that's what we do in America like I'm
moving to Canada
what about Michigan he's looking like
he's got a good chance in Michigan as
well
Luke Linton was hoping for that one Fox
is now calling Florida for Trump there's
not a whole lot of smiles here it's a
scary thing apparently a lot of people
in California tonight are rushing for
the marijuana to comfort themselves Iowa
for Donald Trump and also Wisconsin
don't as loss of those results coming
together in a real surge and that
brought huge cheers to people you can
see what's happening on the floor here
people are very very quiet they are
sitting on the floors here they are
watching these results come in America
see our hook it up now we're going rope
that's all chanting we believe she will
win down at the Clinton rally
headquarters and she's not done yet
Trump wins Wisconsin so sky is calling
Trump winning Wisconsin there the big
networks just called this for Donald
Trump hugs kisses chance
or Hillary Clinton has rung doldrums
concede defeat in the US presidential
election according to TV networks here
and confirm that Donald Trump will be
the 45th President of the United States
[Music]
and I can only say that while the
campaign is over our work on this
movement is now really just beginning
we're going to get to work immediately
for the American people and we're going
to be doing a job that hopefully you
will be so proud of your president
you'll be so proud again it's my honor
there's an amazing evening it's been an
amazing two-year period and I love this
country thank you thank you very much